it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday Follies the democratic debate
provided us with more ridiculous and
hysterical moments than we ever could
have imagined here with all the details
Raymond Arroyo Fox News contributor all
right Raymond you notice some trends
during the debate through through lines
that the audience might have missed I
did Laura the first thing that jumped
out at me was the attempt to subtly lay
claim to a favorite phrase of a former
president as a way to build stature if
only they could have been clearer first
of all let me be very clear let me be
clear let's be clear let's be clear
let's be clear about this look on let's
just be clear two things became crystal
clear for me let me be very clear versus
let's be fuzzy right it looks like Obama
always said that yeah well you did
indeed as will remind you so let me be
clear let me be clear so let me be clear
now let me be clear let me be absolutely
clear and Joe Biden mentioned Obama so
often Laura I thought he might be
running for a third term listen I know
that the senator says she's for Bernie
well I'm for Barack this the president
has done a great deal so I'm proud to
have served with him the Barack turned
the president turned to me and said Joe
when they said we had a plan to get out
he turned to the whole security sim Joe
will organize this Biden's pack even
released an ad Laura to reinforce the
relationship in case you forgot Barack
Obama is an extraordinary man
I watched up close yes character
[Applause]
vice-president but then something funny
happened on stage law Biden couldn't
recall who the president was
I hear this large savings the president
think my friend for her Mon thinks that
the employer is going to give you back
if you negotiate his union all these
years so he called Biden that he called
because Sanders the president there the
port man I my heart always breaks for
him he's so earnest he's so once the
second boy second
he's so Ernie is earnest he's I kind of
like Biden I wish he wants this so badly
I just think you know the the bloom is
off the the lily it's like the glory
days yeah it's just ring stain song
there's a monster bout a moment glory
day yeah
all right things really went off the
rails over Biden when he started
offering parenting advice to low-income
kids play the radio make sure the
television the excuse me make sure you
have the record player on at night the
phone make sure the kids hear words
Laura that answer took this was a pivot
from a question about reparations and he
was trying to get into his plan which is
a home visitation plan where people come
in and help kids talk to them give them
language so he was saying put the radio
waye something on so the kids pick up
more yeah I'm from the government I'm
here to raise your child no thanks that
it is part of the Affordable Care Act
okay then there was Biden's unfortunate
upper palate issue oh four months after
Sandy Hook a measure to require expanded
background checks died on the Senate
floor if you couldn't get it done after
Sandy Hook why should voters give you
another chance because I God done before
I'm the only one up here's ever beat the
NRA
I hope Polident is the the next sponsors
of the debate and then there was Kamala
Harris our guy who looked like she well
she was very relaxed she was I think she
was she she kind of had a cool way of
'la it was kind of a well as admitted to
smoking weed and oh she wasn't toward
joking she looked I'm not saying she has
admitted that in the past she watched
these losses very relaxed Donald
in office on trade policy you know he
reminds me of that that guy in The
Wizard of Oz you know when you pull back
the curtain it's a really small dude I'm
not even gonna take the bait I mean I
would just say hey Joe it's Etta saying
no we can't let's say yes we can
she was real laid-back last I thought
she was pretty good you thought you
thought Camilla Harris was really good
now wait a minute you jumped me for
defending Joe Biden Ernest you're not
and you're gonna defend she was all over
hair I heard of Oz a little do I like
that I like that it was kind of like a
slow roll it was like kind of calm she's
gonna slow roll right off that stage in
the next debate take the other questions
there